nineteen sixty seven marks the 20th
anniversary of the establishment of the
United States Air Force as a separate
military service and it also marks the
60th year of the use of military
aviation as a part of our nation's
defense structure officially our
military aviation began in august 19-7
when Captain Charles Chandler was named
officer in charge of the United States
Army's aeronautical division his staff
to enlisted men the mission studied a
flying machine and the possibility of
adapting its to military purposes the
Wright brothers had made their first
bike in nineteen three and then had gone
to Europe to find a market for their
flying machine won't for our government
in nineteen nine their improved plane
becomes our first military aircraft he
made about 42 miles an hour Glenn
Curtiss another aviation pioneer also
built some of our first military
aircraft but our air power growth was
slow after four years only 41 pilots had
earned these Gold Wing
19 17 we have 55 planes none suited for
combat so our pilots are sent to Europe
and join british french and italians
portland the train and fight in world
war one in the States the Battle of
manufacture is on six hundred million
dollars to build 4,500 aircraft
September eighteen nineteen eighteen the
greatest air battle of the war 1500
Allied aircraft nearly half piloted by
Americans two months later the enemy
capitulate
as we move towards the twenties the
plane became a toy our war trained
pilots turn to barnstorming gypsy flyers
earning their way with any spectacular
sight
but there were other Daredevils with a
more serious vs. flying safety parachute
were not generally accepted to prove
they work many of the test jumps were
made by the inventors themselves the
first cross-country flight as a military
T to the left New York with over 700
gallons of fuel lands at San Diego in
the same era the first airmail service
inaugurated by President Wilson and
carried by military air between
Washington and New York
practice draping missions against group
with anti-aircraft weapons becomes part
of our military aviation training
program and we refine the techniques of
close air support for ground forces
brigadier general Billy Mitchell on the
right insisted that planes could sink
chip our military leaders of the day
watched as he proved his point in a
series of tests the climax is the
destruction of a captured German
battleship the vessel considered
unsinkable in 1923 the barling 32,000
pounds moving along at 61 miles an hour
it didn't make the inventory but it was
a valuable test vehicle for our
aeronautical engineer aerial reviewing
is developed and the famous ? remains a
law for nearly a week
in 1930 we conduct our first polar
maneuvers planes had now flown the ocean
so there was the possibility an enemy
could invade our nation over the Arctic
and we were determined to be prepared
bundles of food dropped to snowbound
Navajo tribes in Arizona in 1932 in one
of the first uses of military air for
mercy's lights the p26 our first metal
covered fighter in production joined the
air force in the early 30s looking like
a praying mantis the benign our first
all-metal monoplane bomber next the b10
it could fly an excess of 200 miles an
hour had retractable landing gear and
was considered the fastest and heaviest
bomber in the world the b-17 makes its
first flight in 1935 it was destined to
become the Flying Fortress of World War
two sep tember first 1939 the war began
when hitler directs the nazi army and
Luftwaffe to attack Poland
next the invasion of holland and belgium
as the powerful Nazi Air Arm and Panzers
moved toward Paris
jun 22nd 1940 france surrenders now only
Great Britain's Royal Air Force remain
for the Luftwaffe to conquer the Nazis
air battle for Britain began on the
other side of the world the Rising Sun
brings dawn and down its Pearl Harbor
December 7 1941 what 14 of our aircraft
managed to get airborne and destroy 10
attacking Japanese four months later
b-25s are launched from the carrier
Hornet there Jimmy Doolittle's Raider
bringing the first impact of the war to
the Japanese
b-17s liftoff from midway in June 1942
to join our Navy's carrier-based
aircraft in meeting a Japanese task
force for the battle that is to mark a
turning point in the war in the Pacific
the mission of the Japanese planes was
to rape midways gun emplacements and
form the way for an invasion but when
our planes hammered back the issue was
decided during the three-day battle
japan lost four carriers two heavy
cruisers three destroyers 275 aircraft
and 4800 men the Japanese offensive in
the mid Pacific was broken in the Far
East another battle the war of logistics
military air flies the home from India
to our fighting forces in China ships
loaded with cargo were waiting
before the war's end we carry more than
1 million tons of supplies over the home
nazi sub in the first half of 42 they
sang 506 allied ship b-24 were one of
the weapons used to meet this menace
equipped with radar they patrol the sea
lanes on seek and destroy mission by
October 242 the killer stuff is
virtually eliminated from our home
waters in Europe the Air Force has
orders to fly through Hitler's back door
and destroy his major oil industry the
refining plans at flow st romania p-38
lightning for in
b20 pourers have their say
and the enemy answers jamming up
thousands of rounds of life
when the argument was over our military
era was victorious we destroyed nearly
ninety percent of the Romanian oil that
was feeding the swastika war machine
DJ
the invasion of Hitler's Europe is
mounted leading the attack air power
plays a major role
interdiction and airlift of food
allied surface forces hit the beaches of
Normandy as ground troops fought for a
foothold our bombers cut enemy lines of
communication and supply long before the
invasion our air forces had virtually
swept the airfields and disguise of
Europe of enemy aircraft General
Eisenhower was able to assure the
invasion force that on d-day if you see
any planes don't worry they'll be our
as the Nazis felt the strike of our air
power in Europe so the Japanese felt the
strike day and night of our new
strategic bombers the b-29 Tokyo burn
surrender comes in September 1945 1947
Congress mates of our air power a
separate and distinct military
department the United States Air Force
its first secretary Stuart Symington its
first chief of staff general Carl spots
for the new Air Force the strategic
bomber is the b-36 the longest range
bomber of its time for the tactical and
air defense functions the f80 and f-86
the first jets are being developed
and already our first experimental
rocket plane is life
1948 the Berlin Blockade nothing can
move in and out of West Berlin over 2
million West Berliners now face
starvation unless they can be fed by
airlift
for 15 months 24 hours a day with cargo
planes finally landing every three
minutes the people of Western Berlin are
sustained entirely by this humanitarian
airlift directed by the United States
Air Force berea 1950 communist North
Korea attacks the Republic of South
Korea
the Communists attack is powerful the
defeat of South Korea seems assured
except that the United States is
committed to aid in their defense
airpower is our only weapon ready to
immediately stem the flow of enemy
troops and we stage aircraft of our far
eastern air forces the 24th division is
flown in to be supported by forces from
15 member countries of the United
Nations air hits hard as our ground
forces dig in
North Korean army has come a long hard
job of driving it back
interdiction with their power destroying
today equipment and supplies the
Communists intend to use tomorrow
September fifteen nineteen fifty
American forces landed him John flanking
the Communists on the west the
Communists are forced back for the Yalu
River and our air power makes a massive
combat air drop behind enemy lines
nearly 4,000 troops and their supplies
then the big stuff jeeps ammo and trucks
in the air battles our fighters maintain
a 10 to 1 victory over the enemy me
the fighting ends in 1953 1954 the Air
Force Academy is established by Congress
to provide a new generation of officers
for the new Air Force
officers trained in aeronautical
sciences and the specialized use of air
power
now we are truly a new airport we build
the b-47 strategy
our series of century fighters the f100
f-101 voodoo the f-102 the 104
Starfighter the f-105 thunderchief the
f-106 delta dart f4 phantom 2 and 4
transports the still reliable c-47 c-54
skymaster c-119 flying boxcar
c-123 provider c-130 Hercules
the 135 transport and Stratotanker c-141
starlifter our determined farmers the
b-52 and the b-58 hustler we had Texas
towers to warn of an enemy air attack
today the dew line is one of our radar
air defenses and bemused can detect
enemy missiles as we develop our missile
force before our first
intermediate-range missile
the famous athletes our first ICBM
in the beginning it had problems just as
our early aircraft had their
but our aerospace technicians found the
answers an atlas becomes a reliable
weapon and a booster for the vehicle
that takes our first close-up pictures
of the Moon Air Force tightened to the
booster for all NASA Gemini flights jun
3 1965 Titan to sends Air Force Major
wife for his famous walk in space in the
same month the free worlds most powerful
booster the titan 3c is successfully
tested
during these same years the air force
brings a new generation of missiles into
the inventory the solid fuel minute man
today this retaliatory force can be
launched in salvos from underground site
in a matter of minutes
experimental vehicles the x-15 a manned
rocket ship and for vertical takeoff and
landing the tri-service HC 142 the
supersonic xb-70 the f-111 with variable
sweep wings the Y f12 a experimental
interceptor for strategic reconnaissance
the sr-71 the Air Force c5a to be our
largest transport aircraft carrying a
quarter of a million pound payload HH
threes modified for midair refueling
become the first choppers to cross the
Atlantic non-stop a new rescue technique
ground-to-air recovery by an hc-130
vietnam
American air power gives unparalleled
support to allies ground forces
it takes air power to move ground troops
into battle
to supply them with ammunition food and
equipment to find the enemy where he
hides and to mark his position for our
fighters you take care power to find and
engage the enemy beyond the range of
ground the penetration it takes air
power to supply remote and surrounded
out both
it takes air power to fight the enemy on
his distant and secret trail
to destroy his far-flung supply lines
and it takes airpower to guard friendly
Hamlet's day and night
and to hit the enemy north and south
even our strategic bombers the b-52s
play a tactical role in Southeast Asia
to convince the enemy that he cannot
hide that he cannot hold the initiative
and that he cannot hope to win
and it takes air power to save our
airmen downed in the water trapped in
the jungles mountains and marshes and it
takes air power to evacuate our sick and
wounded to the United States in only 25
hours behind our air power there are
people airmen who will risk their lives
to save others as quickly as they risk
themselves in the fight for freedom fly
Belgian troops to the troubled Congo
evacuate Belgian refugees
airdrop tweet for the starving
rescue the people of Thailand
give medical aid for the diseased and
the enter
have love for the young
this then is 60 years of military
aviation 60 years that have opened one
of the greatest career fields in the
world to the young people of our country
it is a 60-year history of light and
bold man
tomorrow there will be more pioneers
men of our Air Force who are not afraid
to make decision airmen who think beyond
today men of the aerospace age who are
willing to try what has never been tried
before